it's you up with Nikki Glaser Andrew
Colin is here and now Chelsea Handler is
here Chelsea welcome to the show thank
you for having my god thanks for being
I'm such a I'm so excited you're here
first of all she's here promoting her
book life will be the death of me
you have to get this book at this book
for anyone in your life who you think
might need to go to therapy
this will sell them on it that's what
I'm so excited about this book you
really you were you got into it late I
can't believe you didn't go to therapy
until you I did did it I tried to but I
wasn't like being alright like I was
trying to send your assistant for you at
one point one time I did I was like I
can't go to therapy today Karen can you
go and she and then she came back and
then the next week I go can you just go
again cuz I go I it was cost you know
they charge you to cancel it so I was
like oh it it's a she go
and then finally after like three
sessions I was like how's it going and
she's like I don't know we're talking
about you is that we're supposed to take
notes
[Music]
obviously wasn't taking that seriously
that therapist yeah and then you did
then Trump happened and you were like I
got something's going on with me with my
anger and then you called up a guy that
had been on your show on Netflix that
you had interviewed a therapist and you
went back yeah and I got you know I got
I started to talk after a while I
started to talk about real things but I
went in with the notion that we're not
gonna discuss my childhood and I was I
real quickly told him like my brother
died my mom said but I'm cool I just
need to move forward in a better more
patient manner and I have a lot of anger
towards Trump and you know I'm blah blah
blah so it took but it was the right
time for me and it's embarrassing that
it had to take so long like it but
better late to the party than never
showing up at all I'm so glad you found
it because the way you talk about in
this book sold me on it again cuz I'm
in-between therapists and I gotta tell
you I finished your book on the train on
the way here and I go I'm tearing up
because you're just making so much sense
to me and I got out of this train I went
to a text message from a friend who I
know it suggested a new therapist I
found her suggestion and I wrote an
email to the therapist literally an hour
ago being like let's do it again because
your book and I've been in therapy for
years but I needed some I'm going for
you right I will I mean I'll talk partly
about I'm gonna take a little advantage
for a bunch of sessions and come back to
Nikki and is just like okay so how you
doing great you're just sitting there
sorting out of her problems with a
therapist and reporting back you know
your brother died no I didn't know that
yeah exactly
a lot of things late and like I feel
like you're stumbling my period I only
wear white when I get my period I mean
that's what older women told me to do
I actually went to the gynecologist
yesterday because I'm I haven't been
getting my period do you ever just go
through periods where you're not getting
it you're like this is kind of great I
went to my gynecologist and I'm not
gonna die anytime soon I went to a
gynecologist a couple weeks ago and I
was really excited cuz I woke up and my
head was like soaking wet like I have
like hot sweats
I was like oh it's coming I'm Perry I'm
44 I'm like oh I'm getting probably an
early menopause because I don't have
kids and I heard you get I'm sure that's
not true but you get your you know you
go through menopause earlier I was it
great I go to the doctor I'm like hey I
had hot flashes I'm like my feet are
sticky I'm like so I think we're getting
ready to wrap things up here and she's
like you're about to get your period so
that's PMS and I was like I'm a woman
now I was like let's get this party over
because I'm not in my period anymore no
rap on that it sucks I've been enjoying
not getting it but then I realize that
you do have to get it to be like a
healthy healthy yeah like my bones I
really do feel like there's something
going on do you have a boyfriend right
now no dude I related so much to your
whole thing about pushing men away and
feeling like you don't need them and
feeling your best self when you are
single and being able to get so much
more done I that part of the book made
me cry to just realizing that you're
like maybe I do want a relationship and
I'm realizing it with you me was really
I related to so much of what you said
can we talk about weed like why did you
get into weed so late and what have you
found from like what are the benefits
you found from it I was taking sleeping
pills so like too frequently yeah and I
was having trouble sleeping and so that
was my initial reason to try I used to
take it recreationally but I was never
like a big stoner or anything as more of
a drinker and then with micro dosing and
the educational component that is now
available when you buy something at a
store and it labels everything and tells
you what kind of strain it is and what
THC and CBD ratio is I was like okay
well then now this is now scientific and
there's data behind it and you can
actually know what you're putting into
your mouth
so that was a game-changer and then I
just started using it and I was I like
to enable others that's like a strong
suit of mine I like to get people to use
things that
to help them like my niece has a lot of
anxiety really badly and it was
preventing her from like you know really
flourishing in school and I don't say
flourishing by the way I don't know
where I got that word from The Bachelor
and but you know like she it helped her
calm down when she had to give a
presentation it helps like it helped me
it changed my sleeping patterns and then
I was like started using it during the
day edibles or vaping like I'd go to me
and I'm always in a constant state of
annoyance I find most people incredibly
annoying and I just wish everyone
stopped talking to me you know and then
I was like this can't be the way that
I'm supposed to feel like it's such an
unnatural default zone there must be an
injury as to why I got here still
thinking it had nothing to do with my
brother dying when I was 9 years old
right
still thinking what happened that I
can't identify where is that thing can
someone talk to me and tell me what it
is and write down you never read the
note the brothers dead deal with it okay
he died please you remembered your mom
at one point being like well she's in it
like you had some flare-up at home and
you stormed out and you heard your mom
say to your dad
she's she's in a lot of pain let her
deal with it and you just go helped it
not you had reflecting now you're like
she saw that I was in pain I had no idea
where people would say to me Oh God you
seem so angry and I think what are you
talking about idiot I'm not
angry why do I have to walk around
smiling tell me what you do when there's
a long line and you're trying to buy
something like leave me on that I leave
money either sometimes a lot more money
yeah no seriously I will at an airport
if there is a long line or any line I
will take a magazine or a book usually a
book because I try not to read trash
anymore but I take a book or whatever
I'm gonna buy soda and I wave it in
front of the security camera and then I
wave money and I put it down so that
they know I was here I want to be
accountable but I will not wait in that
line it's too ridiculous it's
and you've never been like in trouble
for doing that like I mean now people
are gonna look out for it leaving a
twenty on itself but I can't deal with
that stuff
you know like when this is another thing
you know when people come to your hotel
room when you order room service you
know this is supposed to be a nice
exchange you're happy you're getting
room service it's a luxury and then they
come and they act like they don't know
where they're supposed to go with the
food it's like who's gotten the wrong
room service delivery ever and that's
never happened to me once that I got
surprise food at a hotel room and I ate
it you know what I mean and that
exchange when they come in and then they
dance around and then they take the
plate off and they put and it's like
buddy get the out I don't let them
in I just grab it from the hallway I
won't let them come in oh well how do
you sign the check I just hold a sign or
no no no but I'll sign and then grab
signing girl but you're not avoiding the
awkward interaction you're avoiding
someone's seeing how disgusting you are
inside here yeah that's what you're
avoiding and you live clean I do
the same thing but I really relate to
this frustration of yes the awkwardness
yes I don't mind the awkward I mind the
slowness of the transaction okay that
can drive me to drink you don't mean
that kind of behavior and it's like when
somebody's leading you for instance
walking you somewhere and they're not in
front of you but they're behind you and
they're leading the way like someone's
walking you two through an airport these
are very relatable examples that I'm
doing I know it's true though it's like
people are I relate to that - people are
so goddamn slow and um and you found
that weed has helped you just with your
anger with that or like you can slow
down I can weed allowed me to slow down
long enough to take meditating seriously
because I could not meditate and I also
living in Los Angeles it is very hard to
listen to phrases like gratitude and
universe it's being thrown around and
overused that you're very I was very
allergic to that kind of language like
stop shut up without kale I don't get it
it's you know we all go to the bathroom
now everybody has kale it's
all right but like with regard to that I
was very resistant because it
represented to me a cliche like Ola you
go to LA you go to therapy go to socotra
stand then you talk about yourself and
you're already a narcissist because
you're famous and bla bla bla so I had a
whole like narrative that I was telling
myself about therapy and that I was too
cool for it
yeah and that and you that you just used
the word narcissist you were scared to
take that test yeah I was like for sure
I'm a narcissist
why would I else would I be behaving
like like why am I so why do I need to
be famous why why do why do you need to
you always need to talk I related to
that I would relate to that as well like
you want the attention on you you said
one time you were learning can you tell
us sorry about learning to wakeboard
this was like made me so sad and I
related into a cosmetic we're in we're
in Croatia uh-huh and we were I was with
a boyfriend who was incredible water
skier and reporter and he was like so I
was really trying to prove to him that I
could do it that I was tough that I can
I like I like to be scrappy you know
like I'm a tomboy I take pride in that
like I loved that growing up that I was
with my brothers all the time you know I
felt like the cool girl which is another
disservice women do to each other by
trying to be the cool girl within a
group of boys so it's like I should have
been hanging out with my sisters
although you know my brothers didn't
teach me anything they gave me no life
skills whatsoever and one of them died
so he had an asshole wakeboarding yeah
so if I got I kept going and kept going
and I couldn't get it I couldn't get it
I was hitting the water wiping out one
time out to another and it was like four
hours and so we were had rented this
boat and all my friends were on this
boat watching me for the first twenty
minutes and then they were on it loser
give up you can't do it and they went
inside and then I just spent the next
four hours like I'm gonna get up I'm
gonna get up and then finally when I did
get up I looked over and to wave at all
of my friends and everybody had gone
inside
[Laughter]
that you feel fulfilled at all I felt
like a prio in like Titanic I was like
no but I'm saying when no one saw it yes
and then I came crashing down this is
the second time something like this is
happening it's yeah that's a painful
moment but do you think that if you
would have come to all these
realizations earlier on in your career
where you I don't need to be talking all
the time I don't need to be the center
of attention I don't need to make
everyone left do you think you would
have achieved the things you've achieved
had you not had that drive to constantly
be on I think that there is a
combination of that ambition that is
coupled with you know this deflection of
real like I didn't want you know the
vulnerability wasn't an option so the
other option was to be tough you know
what I mean so that's what I chose so
that trajectory sticks together and is
coupled with a fast career and a fast
moving and do this and do that and be in
charge and you know the power you get by
being a powerhouse and saying whatever
you want happens in every capacity you
know that you have to be a really
healthy person to get all of that and
still be okay and for a long time I
really was and then for a long time I
was not mm-hmm for so I thought I was
like oh I can handle this everyone say
you're so great at this you don't get
annoyed when people come up to you on
the street and take pictures which I
never do you know I try and be always
like like little things that I could
pinpoint that I was doing well at yeah
and then when I started you know and now
like and then going into therapy after
the election when I was really in a
state of like okay I have something I
need to fix I don't know what it is then
I could reflect back at the times and
realize oh that's why there was there
was a lot of light and then there was a
lot of dark mm-hmm you know yeah so in a
way it did propel you but it didn't have
to be as I could have done myself of
service by getting to therapy about ten
years earlier again I don't like to
judge myself too much because you know
you can let the public do that for you
but I don't want to be too hard on
myself then you know it's it's it's
powerful to embrace you know I'd also
don't want to be a crybaby and be
okay so for me writing this book was the
most vulnerable thing I've ever done and
it was hugely cathartic because I would
sit in airports across the world bawling
while I was writing because that's where
I write most of my stuff that's and
lounges or on planes and I was like this
feels right this is right you should do
this no matter what if like in the
beginning my editor Julie growl who's
sitting over there trying to pretend
like she's busy great job or ignoring
her client she she was like you have
something deeper inside of you and I
didn't have an editor who'd like my last
book I tried to say that to my editor I
was like hey I think I need to write
about my mom dying or I think and she's
like I don't care what you write just
give it to me like yeah they wanted to
put a book out and it and I put a book
out and I participated in that and I
didn't want that to do do that again so
for this the catharsis of it and writing
about and getting it out and putting it
on paper feels like I extinguished a big
part of my pain and it's not like I'm
cooked and I'm fixed and I'm great no
it's like I'm on I got myself back on
the right track and now I have to go and
get better in every possible way that I
can it's so cool to see because I mean
this is your sixth book you've had you
have a lot of books under that you've
put out and you think like oh you you
probably have covered it all in those
books but this is the firt I think I
read your first one and then I just I
devoured this one it is so vulnerable
and as someone I feel like I always say
too much I over share all the time and
for me to be like wow she admitted that
it was really it gave me it made me feel
more fearless in saying what is really
going on with me and acknowledging my
white privilege that's something that
you really dig into in this book and I
know that your you have a documentary
coming out about that and that's a
sensitive topic because you feel like am
I even allowed to talk about my white
privilege but you just lean into it and
you're just telling the truth I think
that you know you have to tell the truth
if you're like you know especially if
you've a comedic background like that is
that you know you don't have a choice
but to tell the truth it's the what you
do as a stand-up and I that is my need
like you know for a long time in the
last couple of years I was like
what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to do with my life what is I
can't possibly just be doing a talk show
like that doesn't feel right for me what
is my true purpose or what is my Drive
and so to do something and feel the
integrity of the work be at a different
level because of the amount of focus you
put into something yes I had never done
one thing at a time in my life I'd never
written a book and that's it like it was
a book a show and a tour is a book a
show on a tour for six years straight
and so to be able to do this book to do
this tour and to be present and to not
be shit-faced and to be like you know my
shows dude it shows this book I'm
telling you buy it for any girl guy
anyone in your life who just knew is not
tapping into their anger or their
emotions and you can see it and maybe
you don't even know what's going on with
them this will help them it will it will
start the conversation for them with
themselves about someone who thought
they had it all figured out but it all
means you did I mean your career has
been insanely even the most successful
successful you could be to see you go
actually I don't have it figured out was
eye-opening to me because I follow you
and thought oh that's all I want to be
is Chelsea Handler I want that respect
in the business I want from my peers
from fans and to see you admit that no I
need to shut the foot like you mean like
I need to shut the up I'm like I
tell myself that all this stop talking
and and then oh I related so much when
you go well that your therapist is like
you work too hard you're running all the
time and you go well widen a me sleeping
20 hours and he's like you're exhausted
and I always beat myself up when I sleep
a lot
but it's cuz you run yourself ragged it
makes complete sense yeah and I really I
love how vocal you are about weed now
because I've found it to be extremely
medicinal for me I have a lot of guilt
wrapped up a minute because I don't
drink and at first I started out being
completely sober from both and then when
I started using weed again I felt like
I'm not sober anymore and so I have a
lot of guilt and you being so outspoken
about smoking we are doing whatever
edibles is made me feel like okay I'm
not I'm on to something that it actually
makes me better let's make you better
and listen I can relate to that and you
should not have
any guilty this is something that grows
out of our that any construct that you
have guilt and I know you know all of
this but like any guilt that you have is
a concept of societal this is a
plant that grows out of our ground and
we have illegalized it and criminalized
it and we are gonna go into an area in
the next 20 years where it's going to
become legal throughout this country and
many others and we are going to look
back at this time as the prohibition of
marijuana and you are right to use it it
is medicinal if you find in this earth
is medicinal and we're sitting here
buying pills from the
pharmaceutical industry who's making
everybody into an addict
yeah smoke weed I know and I have so
much guilt wrapped up in it because but
I do feel like when you talked about the
effect of when you pop out an edible and
then it clicks it you beautifully
described the feeling where you forget
that you've taken an edible it clip it
pop they suddenly you get high or
whatever and you just your perception
ships it's not like you're like suddenly
like whoa colors and music but you just
pay attention to something that you
wouldn't have paid attention to everyone
becomes a little bit some more sparkly
sparkly yeah word you'd use and it was
perfect and I feel that it is so good
for me in conversation to smoke weed
sometimes to shut up and listen more to
for my comedy it is and and obviously
you can abuse any kind of substance and
there are times where I'm like okay you
didn't need to be high for that yeah if
you sure or whatever but are you sober
from alcohol did you quit drinking yeah
quit drinking like eight years ago
and so weed for me when I got back into
it I was like I'm just I'm using
something again to not feel and yeah I
do it I do that with weed sometimes they
don't want to feel my feelings so I get
high but then I feel them in a different
way yeah I agree with you I don't really
think there's any problem with weed you
can argue that it's a filter and yeah if
you're blotto doll day but it's like
people I mean yeah then you're not
knowing what's happening but like it's
an enhancement yes it helps it if if
that's if I needed a gateway drug to get
me to meditate you know what I mean weed
calmed me down long enough that I could
sit still and not insert myself and it
slows my reaction time down which for me
is good because I talk too much and fast
and so when I have a chance to thought
like there
just no benefit you can't beat yourself
up about that the guilt you got to
extinguished it and I don't know how I
wish I could tell you no I think you
just did you really have like watching
your Instagram and and just seeing you
talk so much about it and you're
developing a wean line and you're doing
all this research her she got her sister
really high like gave her an edible and
then you were like interviewing your
sister about the effects of it for your
weed line like I can't wait for your
weed line because you've done so much
research and I I I don't I can't see
that research when I go to the store in
these products they all look like
they're packaged in a way to just sell
it to me and it's like cute it looks
like a little I'm gonna send you a care
package I can do stuff I have come wait
to try your stuff because you've done
you've done the work on it and um I
wanted to just talk to you about though
relationships you nailed it
you're talking to your therapist and
your book would wait I want to say one
more thing about weed because I think
it's important for women also that are
listening and for us like we have to
empower and emboldened it's a male drug
like men to have no problem lighting up
in a restaurant smoking a joint walking
down the street women are not doing that
and we need to be they don't get that -
yes okay
I am I am doing that I am I do that and
I do vape it yeah it's so convenient
yeah and I'm like what's wrong
something's off it's me there's no
sparkly going on over here at all yeah
it's bad today in the book you've had
two serious relationships in your adult
life and your therapist goes that's not
enough right yeah I relate to that I
haven't I've had one and I often
attribute it to the fact which you as
say as well as like I'm a sassy brash
bitch in men straight men aren't feeling
that they're not what are we to what do
I do
well you have to find a foreigner first
of all I would ask you about that what
they're into it well there they there's
a language barrier they don't know what
you're saying it's better if there's a
little bit of like a language you know
what I mean like you don't speak both
languages
yeah there's confusion because
that way men are like oh that's she's
funny and cute they don't realize like
what's going on I mean I know what you
mean and we are in a place where I
believe me it's hard I have so many
people that I know in my life that are
like where are we supposed to meet a guy
and it's like listen they're out there
somebody is out there yeah there are too
many people in this world there's a lot
of people out there so like there are
multiple boyfriends that are out there
viewers that you're gonna find but I
know what you mean it's hard to say like
cuz you're like what am I supposed to
have a different personality and pretend
I'm someone else to get a guy yeah and
that's a that's what I'm doing a lot of
times is I'm trying to be a different
person because I need to try I need to
be more feminine or I need to just be
quiet and just ask him about him yeah
share my feelings and I read all these
books that tell me - I mean Whitney
Cummings found a boyfriend because she
read a book she her husband I go how did
you get that guy you've been bad with
men forever
you've been vocal about it you seem
really happy and she's like I read this
book getting - I do it's the dumbest
book but that helped me and it's pretty
much just like shut the up let him
talk it's really his dude she read it
and found a boyfriend from it - it works
it does yes and letting him talk yet
letting it's yeah but it evolved anal
and then turn around my old brain knows
my old girlfriend but you know yep tried
and true he's here for me and we know
how old this thing is yeah 37 yeah it
was born a year after me I grew arms
late your ma you came out of your mom
and kept your hand in her that's what
she wanted yeah she enjoys a good
fisting just one arms sorry mrs. Collins
it's fine she's can't here anymore
mm-hmm so I I think my old brain what I
was mouthing to her oh because she can't
hear anymore Oh
she wouldn't understand you blitz
lip-reading for you no one understands
whatever you whatever I say actually
you're talking it all looks like a horse
chewing on peanut butter that's how we
get him to talk on the show we given
these bars what is this
just this condom
[Music]
what's like the number-one thing about
like a girls look that like when she
does something where you're like I'm
glad that they did that like a lot of
guys are like I don't even notice when
they get their nails don't even know
like is there something that you could
point to that like oh you do appreciate
when girls do
I mean lives more than nails for sure oh
really like lipstick yeah you could tell
it yeah you look at a face you don't
look at hand through then you look at a
hand secondary you like lips with gloss
on them more than not yes really I would
never have thought that why they're more
juicy so I just I also feel like guys
don't want to get it on them yeah I
don't
yeah I don't think guys hmm how's a guy
been like don't miss me because I have
because you have yeah I put on lipsticks
and I sometimes don't wear it because
it's like clearing grace was like I
don't want to get gloss on me if it's
fiery red then that could come up in
your head yeah okay um do you notice
when we don't shave our legs yes you do
even though your legs are hairy you can
feel the hair on ours
you're just trained to like hairless
legs
same with armpits a little bit of armpit
hair just like in this century like
women before the disposable razor women
did not have to shave their legs every
woman because because to get a shave you
would have to go to a barber like
disposable razors men didn't even shave
at home and so women to go to a barber
to get your leg shave no one did it
women just never shaved and because of
the disposable razor I think within the
20th century what's what popular is
shaving the likes before then women had
hairy legs forever and it was not even
thought that you would be hairless it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be but it's like
you know it's like it is required and
another day I dry shaved yeah my guy was
leaving to go I was going to go to a set
but there was a guy there that I was
like he might if he's feeling a little
bit saucy tonight he might like touch my
leg so I need to be shaving on no but I
was like maybe my pants will come up or
something like well I would feel like a
woman if you shaved the juice your calf
you should be fine it's usually whenever
death the gene will come off being it
when I'm feeling it yeah so you'll just
see like a few hairs
and then you're like well if she's shown
if she's not shaving right there it just
gets worse but I I know I shouldn't feel
that way I think I I shouldn't be over
well that's sensitive to be honest with
me could you be into a girl and then see
hair black hair on her ankles chins
area and be like nah never ever didn't
like hooked up with you yeah like oh
here's great and then you see that and
you're like it turns you off a little
bit is there what can instantly turn you
off from a woman not your hair really
yeah oh boy
I always know my arm putting hair around
you I love that I do that okay yeah it
makes me really nauseous great not good
I mean it's actually interesting cuz
like I've seen girls nowadays a lot of
them will have long I think I just
shaved the other night yeah you're good
am i there might be a little crevice I
don't know there's hair yeah that's not
good yeah bad should be shot you want to
see this that's a little much I think
you want to see this no no no I know I
know it's bad it's bad I did I just get
caught Louise did I loo in no that's bad
you have to be funny you are funny
and if you took your dick out I would
just like leave hi it's Nikki Glaser
from you up with Nikki Glaser you're
watching a clip from our show tune in
every Tuesday for a new clip from you up
with Nikki Glaser why are you here